joining us now former White House
communications director founder managing
partner of skybridge Capital Anthony the
mooch scour Moochie and Fox News
correspondent at-large Geraldo Rivera
you know the media is is so they were so
cruel to her as it relates to she's
dating somebody you know it's none of
their business number one and then you
know
oh she admits she told the white light
to me this is what a white lie is the
president would love to do the interview
he's just it's a nice way of saying no
or you look you look great when you
don't think the person looks greatly a
person in the world that hasn't told a
white lie and I'll identify the biggest
liar in the room Sean so that's a
ridiculous statement the the real thing
about this and the media lies everyday
well yeah but they like rolling people
like hope and broken glass to see if
she'll break okay she's made out of
steel so obviously she won't break she's
a wonderful person I'll tell she's she's
one of the least malicious people I've
ever met in my life she's dedicated
she's charming she's thoughtful and at
the end of the day she's gonna have an
unbelievable career of Shawn she's
already 29 unbelievable hope if you're
watching my agent has called me and said
please let me know I'll give her a call
she can work at the Fox News show
anything you want hope I just put it
that way he's an all-star Hollywood
agent but my point is is that this woman
is an entrepreneur above everything else
you're an entrepreneur as you know you
built this from nothing look what the
president did starting with her and
Corey Lewandowski and and his children
to where he is there's all the respect
and a great and love and support and
kindness that you can imagine rather I
saw from the beginning I was there it
was her and it was Corey in was 7 days a
week and it was the look president Trump
will wear out a lot of people and she
hung the whole time was there the whole
time and what's so unbelievable to me
Geraldo did you ever like you don't want
to tell somebody would never given you
the interview will will try isn't that
what a white lie is and the media's
blown that up into something that it
never was or getting into a personal
life and cameras are following to her to
our apartment or a taxicab
it's pretty despicable how they've
treated her oh they cut her up they cut
her up like muggers Shawn nobody is
indispensable in the White House except
for the president with the possible
exception of the chief chef John Kelly
general John Kelly but hope Hicks comes
as close as they come she was a trusted
loyal friend you and I know about
loyalty we know about friendship we know
about trust the president could trust
her he's trusted her for three years she
has taken this from the candidate the
longshot candidate the buckaroo the wild
maverick helped mold him into the
candidate that he became to win the
presidency and then in the first year in
office she has been a key aide she has
been by his side but she has been
whittled down she's been worn down and I
think the House Intelligence Committee
and how they dealt with her and how they
slandered her that coming on the heels
mooch mentioned the whole Rob Porter
thing you know she's had a lot she
helped draft that statement on Air Force
One about the Donald Trump jr. meeting
at Trump Tower she's gone through a lot
she's very young she's been very
effective she's been very loyal she
would be sorely missed I lament this
this is bad news you know Mercedes lap
we know her she was with Fox News for
you know many years she's the White
House director of strategic
communications she would be a
replacement that I could endorse but I
think there's no doubt that hope picks
will be mishaan Anthony I agree in the
sense that she'll be missed
you know Geraldo is also right it's the
president well I would say Pence is the
vice president Pence is way more
indispensable than say chief of staff
Kelly I mean that's just my opinion the
other thing is these guys should start
appointing people like Rick or now and
and start doing the job the board by the
way I don't know I mean grinnell this is
the German country the third fourth
largest economy why don't we have an
ambassador there so so there's a lot of
noise I think they send for Waldo what
do you think it or although I got
another ambassadorship for a-rod oh I'm
gonna send you a Reince Priebus wanted
to send me Antarctica
but so far we're doing okay with the
Penguins is it I think Geraldo would do
good in Antartica or anywhere he was
he'd find a way you know to have a
police siren behind him as even reports
I know him all right
love you both thank you Ricans don't do
well in A&R deny the hopes gonna do
great no but I think the thing about
hope Hicks we can't overlook the fact
that she was remarkable for her age she
was a steady presence she was a and I
don't know you know I can't speak for
other reporters but she was my lifeline
to the president when I needed to speak
to the president or I wanted to be with
the president like the longer just a
week and half ago she was everyone's
life like she taught you every one's
life and she would actually say I hope
the president can there's hope with four
phones and that's how she operated which
was an amazing testament to her